lockdown orders and fear of the
coronavirus caused economic activity to
plunge
and unemployment to skyrocket at an
unprecedented rate
the first task of the next president
will be to deal with the economic
destruction
that the pandemic has brought the
president should not confuse economic
growth for economic strength
the economy will continue to recover
rapidly throughout the second half of
2020
with double-digit gdp growth but these
growth rates are relative to the second
quarter of 2020 when gdp plunged to the
32
annual rate why does this matter because
it's important to recognize that despite
exploding economic growth
the economy is still very weak and these
eye-popping projections are more an
indication of past economic weakness
than current economic strength they
reflect a fast
climb out of a very deep hole and there
is much more climbing left to do
the economy will still need fiscal
support to avoid a slow and sluggish
recovery
and to prevent short-term economic
damage from causing
deeper problems that will hurt the
economy for years to come
what policies do you think the next
president should pursue to support the
economy
let us know in our poll and let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos
from aei